Now it's being compared to
finding a needle in a haystack.
But imagine if that needle
were highly radioactive.
Well, search
crews scanning a remote highway
in Australia
actually managed
to find this tiny radioactive capsule
after it was missing for six days.
It's the size of a small coin
and appears
to have fallen off the back of a trans
port truck.
Crews looking for it
combed an area roughly
the length of the UK
When you consider
the scope of the research area,
locating this object
was a monumental challenge.
The search crews
have quite literally found
the needle in the haystack.
CNN correspondent Mark Stewart
joins us live from Hong Kong.
Great news,
an extraordinary effort
as well in this search.
Indeed, back
so the story is
just so intriguing for some reason.
Let me give you some context.
This is a Hong Kong coin.
It's very similar in size to a US dime.
It is that small.
I want to make sure you can see it
here of the skyline.
Basically,
this capsule that was
found is used for mining.
Here's the history.
The capsule
was discovered
about six
days, six days
after it went missing,
likely falling off a truck.
Now, eventually,
it was found off the side of a road
by crews
who are using special radiation
detection equipment.
It was not found too far from the Rio
Tinto mine
suggesting it fell off the truck
soon as it left.
But the potential search area for
this was enormous. Vast.
You mentioned the size of the U.K.,
I believe
we are talking about distance here
longer than the California coastline.
A perimeter was set up.
And so now the goal is to transport
this capsule in a lead container
to the health department to a facility
they have in Perth.
But this was very concerning
because human exposure could cause
skin burns,
radiation sickness,
even a risk of cancer in some cases.
And just 24 hours ago, authorities felt
that the chance of finding
it was very slim.
Now, Max,
they have to determine how this happened
in the first place,
how it fell off that truck likely.
Okay, Mark.
Sure. It's fascinating Thank you.